Biden wants to fight Trump that is the
story of the week this would be the
greatest day for the makers of bengay
when a guy who ended up becoming our
national leader said I can grab a woman
anywhere and she likes it and then said
I made a mistake a mistake but they
asked me what I like to debate this
gentleman and I said no I said if we
were in high school I'd take you behind
the gym and beat the hell out of him
that is some tough talk I kick your ass
if I were in high school
that's like saying I'd kick your ass if
I were a giant clam it's a biological
impossibility
anyway Trump took that bait faster than
Kevin Spacey on the set of To Catch a
Predator
the original joke was worse all right
just remember that Trump tweeting that
Biden would go down hard and crying all
the way now Biden was speaking at a
rally against sexual assault urging
responsibility but that message was
drowned because these two want to throw
down the former VP and the current
President of the United States of
America Biden 75 Trump is 71 together
that's like 300 years two old guys
fighting shirtless it'd be like watching
two pieces of driftwood grappling and
low tide
or to tube socks packed with prunes
tumbling in a dryer but I'd watch it I'd
watch every second of it
imagine imagine imagine the pay-per-view
are you ready for an early bird brawl a
melee of the mature a Geritol
free-for-all I'll fix it at fracas and
nonstop action with two men attraction
that set your local arts to stun because
it's the battle look of really old guys
2040 with the combined age of 150 years
it's Joe the curmudgeon bludgeon Biden
versus Donald knuckle sandwich Trump
potential forget an altercation
featuring an omelet station they were
born before computers they can remember
when people rode horses and they get
colonoscopies regularly good for them
because it's really important you've
never seen a rumble this slow this
senior scrap is 12 rounds of walk word
sounds a clumsy tussle requiring the
bleep breath through the bridge and
first 100 people who arrive get up I've
done supply butterscotch candy
so grab your ensuring your most
comfortable orthotics because it's the
Battle of the really old guys 2014
featuring an undercard match between Liz
bokken Pocahontas Warren versus brawl
and Betsy two bucks
[Music]
[Applause]
now this is all fantasy they're not
really gonna fight for one thing either
of them want to mess up their hair but
if this is Joe's audition to take on
Trump in 2020 I think he's making a
mistake he's trying to steal voters from
Trump and this is what he lifts from him
his least appealing trait Trump's got
better ones his strong stance on terror
his love for law and order his fun
rallies that's why we live with Trump's
often rough talk believe me if he
weren't getting lower unemployment or
tax cut bonuses and talks with North
Korea Trump the personality wouldn't be
half as popular fact is everyone has a
talent a skunk has won a peacock has won
but a skunk can't impersonate a peacock
or vice versa so Joe stick to what you
know like hugs here we go look at that
goes on a little too long she's feeling
uncomfortable yeah all right enough he
just can't let go
[Applause]
let us welcome tonight's guest he's so
bright you'll see spots when he leaves
he's the leading philosophers
psychologists and all-around godfather
of the Internet his YouTube channel has
almost 1 million subscribers his latest
book has 12 rules for life it's
University of Toronto psychology
professor Jordan Peterson alright he's
nailed more rolls than a perverted Baker
the great actor daniel roebuck he's got
an excellent new film out ball getting
brace she's no waitress but she brings a
lot to the table
Nats review reporter captive he can't
play hide and seek impact a wrestler in
my massive sidekick Tyrus
dr. Peterson you are a psychologist a
renowned psychologist if you look at
America as a patient how would you
diagnose it when you see how our
political I all the political conflicts
are going now split personality
obviously yes definitely yeah yeah
tribal increasingly yeah yeah I think
that might be driven by the failure of
the standard media at least to some
degree mm-hmm you meet CNN Fox News do
you Nord News yeah well I think that
that as readership and viewership
shrinks it's easier to use clickbait and
to use tactics of what indignation to
attract decreasing viewership mm-hmm and
that that might be driving the
polarization to some degree yeah it's
partly a technological transformation
yeah it seems like in terms of
polarization people people are seeking
order out of chaos right they'd like to
hear the things that they want to hear
and that's just the way we all are we
just like to be around people that are
like us yeah well we we but we in the
past we've been able to maintain a
reasonably civil dialogue yeah I haven't
seen things this polarized I don't think
since the 1970s since the early 1970s
yeah so it's kind of an ugly mess and I
think a large part of that I do believe
is driven by the by the universities and
their their continual production of
people who are radically left in their
political orientation
the identity politics that is that is
now putting the group before the
individual yeah it's a terrible thing to
do that and it is an invitation to
tribalism and tribalism is an invitation
to conflict mm-hmm so you'd think would
that we the great one of the great
achievements of the West as far as I'm
concerned is that we figured out a long
time ago maybe several thousand years
ago that the individual should always be
superordinate to the state mm-hmm right
that's the great discovery of Western
civilization all right
professor Dan yeah doctor I was a doctor
in Los dr. ARS you were a doctor I was i
I was nowhere near as smart as doctor
dr. Preston Jordan though but I am
intrigued by this whole idea that we're
I mean we love sports and that's
tribalism right we're all into that yes
so we've done that and I always thought
that maybe was the thing that we that we
put instead of like fighting we all had
sports the yeah my wrong I don't know
I'm just I just came up with I was
trying to act smart you did a great job
you did so I want to your by the same
rules right so there's an overarching
theme of cooperation right we all know
that's a deal and we could get along
tribally as long as we had an
overarching system of cooperation and at
least in principle that was respect for
the individual now that that in itself
is under attack and that's a very bad
thing yeah yeah Tyrus Tom what you think
I'm processing still I'm more upset
about that you think everyone wants to
hang around people that look and act
like them you know how lonely I would be
for a 6/8 black and Scottish powerlifter
conservative
just be walking just saddle man like my
best friend me Sudan who just passed
away the Rhino that'd be it I mean I and
this is the media's fault yet mmm this
by CNN and the super left there look
even if you don't they're shoving people
in the fight right button actually made
those comments but in the before the
election mm-hm and he was at a rally
where the word that came up and he
explained why because he was talking
about how important and how strongly he
felt against men saying inappropriate
things towards women and doing things
and and you know we all know about the
grabbing whatever and that was the issue
they just took that and realized he said
he wants to fight Trump yeah your
president bonfire like damn Mama's just
accept this money at a rally just makes
you know they literally are just trying
to push anybody into a fight with Trump
and it's that was the first time he said
it not this latest time we're talking
about yeah he said it before and they
brought it back late was brand new
Ryan was retelling the story of what he
said before but that information is not
needed because maybe we could throw him
to fight Trump nobody wants to fight
Trump right now nobody wants to go no
one wants to start running for president
now well it's completely you're gonna be
forgotten you nobody can do Trump well
cat except for Trump like you can't be
like if you could be pretty rough and
and sloppy with his rhetoric if you try
to do it then he comes right after you I
think we saw that in the debates
remember when little Marco tried to be
tough and he just ended up looking
absolutely ridiculous I just wanted to
say that normally mm-hmm I would love to
watch 270 something year old men fights
yes however not when my tax dollars are
paying for at least one of their medical
expenses
I will not allow this you know maybe
President Obama was right about
Obamacare maybe he was just planning for
this fight
but do you think so we're like would
they fight by the markets of Queensbury
rules that's you know like what they
both it ok agree with no punching of the
face we just you know this is a good
point we got to wrap it up but you know
what this is progress it's not a duel
like we've moved from dual service and
then who's the dude that what's the
Hamilton you could make a musical out of
this Aaron yeah like hey this Hampton
Aaron Burr right I don't know my history
all I know is that they wrapped back
then according to the musical throw to
commercial stuff go to commercial stop
my trouble